I was allowed to see it at the Crystal Palace.
My question is, how did Koi get that strength?
You have a power unmatched by the hero of the shield
.
Dogeza if you want
It's the world I was
in When you ask someone something, just rub your head on the ground
You can also escape from
true
Thinking that I defeated the monster of the wave Do you have hair that you want to fight with
?  No Fukue I'll absolutely forgive you
Taxation
Yes, I'll make
your damn trade atone for that sin No
matter how dirty you use it
I will definitely protect my friends I
won't let you steal anything from me again
Let's touch one finger I'll drive you to the
end of the earth and make you regret that you were born eme
[music]